[Música]
y en nuestro nuevo espacio en directo
américa tendremos a diariamente un
invitado para tratar un tema en
profundidad hoy 24 de septiembre del año
2001 cuando aumentamos nuestra
programación en español a 24 horas
compartiremos este espacio con nuestro
director álvaro sierra pero antes
revisamos nuestro recorrido hasta hoy en
un informe preparado desde nuestra
redacción por luis fernando montes y
juana pupiales
buenos días hoy es un día muy especial
en este momento se enciende la señal de
france 24 en español el momento de la
cultura en france 24 y santiago porque
este mes se estrenó durante el festival
de cine hoy comenzó bien lo decía en la
segunda fecha de la fase de grupo de la
liga de campeones de europa bienvenidos
a la crónica historia de france 24
bienvenidos a reporteros de france 24
historias contractilidad unos jefes de
estado ya han llegado aquí a lima para
la octava cumbre de las américas ha
terminado la manifestación de los
chalecos amarillos aéreos
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión especial
de inmigrantes esta es la primera
manifestación de marzo que tenemos muy
felices porque duplicamos nuestros
tiempos de programación al aire desde
este preciso momento estaremos 12 horas
al día estamos exactamente a 12 horas de
este divorcio de la eurocámara ha votado
a favor del acuerdo de salida
materializando sea así el break si
continúa aumentando el número de muertos
por el coronavirus procedente de hojas
de que empezó la epidemia y hasta hoy
aquí hay muchas medidas de seguridad por
ejemplo al entrar nos miden la
temperatura y utilizan el reconocimiento
facial la decisión dramática y sin
precedentes de declarar todo el país en
cuarentena toque de queda que obliga a
todos los ciudadanos a mantenerse en su
casa hospitales y morgues se encuentran
completamente desbordados de la
situación de kobe 19 ahora trabajamos de
este caso nos adaptamos desde nuestros
hogares para llevarles toda la
información una semana de la mayor
catástrofe no no de la historia
la victoria el candidato
el papá y luego estar a su lado por
cuatro años llevándole s toda la
información internacional hoy 24 de
septiembre aumentamos nuestro compromiso
con ustedes ofreciéndoles 24 horas de
programación completamente en español
nos acompaña de lunes a viernes todas
las mañanas con directo américa nuestro
nuevo programa matinal ahí los espero y
finalmente estrenamos álvaro directo
américa y pasamos a 24 horas de
programación en español qué felicidad
tenemos todas a tener reacciones jefe
balance de sus últimos cuatro años sí sí
un saludo muy importante para la
audiencia hoy es el primer momento de
las 24 horas de esta cadena que creamos
hace cuatro años unas felicitaciones tan
grandes para raúl y para todo el equipo
que ha hecho esto posible estamos
estamos cansados y felices felices mucho
más felices que cansados por todo el
trabajo que ha significado esto y el
resultado que lo tenemos a la vista acá
balance estos cuatro años empezamos una
pequeña cadena hace cuatro años el 26 de
septiembre 2017
con 6 horas al aire apenas teníamos una
franja de la mañana una franja en la
noche fuimos creciendo pasamos a 12
horas al cabo de dos años y medio
pasamos parcialmente a 16 horas con la
pandemia con muchos programas sobre la
pandemia y finalmente hemos llegado a la
altura de crucero de cualquier cadena de
noticia internacional que son las 24
horas ahí estamos las audiencias han
crecido de una manera exponencial diría
yo desde el comienzo y tenemos hoy en
día tenemos en los tres países donde
medimos audiencia de televisión tenemos
3.3 millones de telespectadores por
semana en argentina colombia y méxico
llevamos ya una buena parte del año
anterior 2020 y de este año sobrepasando
los 3 millones de visitantes únicos
tuvimos momentos del comienzo de la
pandemia en que pasamos de 4
tenemos cerca de 94 millones de vídeos
vistos en youtube y en facebook digamos
los números son muy alentadores pero
desde el punto de vista del balance y
para mí como director y para él y para
la audiencia que lo más importante el
balance principal es editorial hemos
logrado presentar una oferta informativa
de reportajes de programas que se
diferencia de otras cadenas
internacionales en la que son muy
importantes los derechos de la minoría y
los derechos de la mujer tenemos un
programa dedicado a eso en en una
programación en la que áfrica es
importante un continente al que se le
presta muy poca atención y que es clave
de una cadena laica una cadena no
religiosa digamos así que respeta por
supuesto los valores religiosos pero que
es parte digamos de esos principios de
la fe desde la filosofía tradicional de
la ilustración francesa del liberalismo
en el sentido filosófico de la palabra
de la laicidad y de otros valores que
son claves en lo que hacemos en france24
hablabas de los programas agro que por
supuesto vamos a tener estas 24 horas de
programación en nuevos programas y le
pido que entonces nos adelante algo
sobre todo a nuestra audiencia que puede
empezar a ver a partir de hoy bueno hay
tres componentes que se hacen como el
esqueleto de lo que estamos haciendo en
24 horas el primero lo tenemos aquí se
llama américa es este programa que
empezamos hoy es una matinal que va a
estar con ustedes todos los días de
lunes a viernes de 7 a 9 hora de bogotá
quito lima la segunda es digamos el
centro de lo que hacemos es la parte
informativa vamos a tener noticias de 15
minutos en un momento breve corto pero
en el que una persona queda
completamente informada de la actualidad
latinoamericana y de la actualidad
mundial del canal con estos noticias de
15 minutos 24 horas diarias lo que
quiere de ser una ventanita al mundo de
américa latina es contarle al mundo
sobre américa latina pero también son
una ventana del mundo hacia américa
latina y tener información como he dicho
de todos los continentes y todos los
lugares y el tercer la tercera gran
novedad el programa el debate que
emitimos todos los días a las 19 20
empezamos a emitirlo todos los días a
las 19 20 a partir del lunes próximo del
lunes 27 se hará cotidianamente antes lo
hacíamos sólo una vez a la semana y
finalmente vamos a tener una serie de
sorpresas interesantes que vamos a
introducir algunas a partir de la semana
próxima y otras gradualmente hasta hasta
entrante vamos a tener una serie de
programas que cubren la actualidad de
los países hechos por nuestros
corresponsales vamos a tener programas
desde europa vamos a tener reportajes
exclusivos de los corresponsales
cubiertos en un programa semanal vamos a
tener mucha más información de francia
seguirá lo verán en un rato aquí en en
directo américa tenemos un pequeño
espacio que se llama directo parís con
nuestros periodistas en la redacción de
france 24 la invitación entonces álvarez
a que se queden con france24 para que
pueda disfrutar de toda la programación
que con mucho cariño y mucho esfuerzo
mucho profesionalismo hemos preparado
para toda la audiencia gracias por estar
con nosotros era álvaro sierra director
general de france 24 en español nosotros
continuamos y vamos a nuestra segunda
hora de programa directo américa
[Música]